the day started with a yoga class
cause it turns out if I don't
not only am I a sore bitch
I'm also just a bitch
and cause I'm irrevocably deep in my
handmaid's era at the moment
the first thing I did when I got home was make bread
praise be
then I learnt that apparently
I'm the only person who actually looks in the fridge in this house
which means I'm also the only person who
notices when it needs to be cleaned
Blessed be the fruit
vegetables and other things I keep in the fridge
I was determined to not dedicate all of my
spare time to the upkeep of my house
today instead
I just dedicated most of my spare time
to the upkeep of the house today
being a homemaker is so rewarding
I'm not too sure yet what the reward is
but one day when I figure it out
rest assured you'll be the first to know
actually I might have recently stumbled across one such reward
my new toilet cleaner is pink
and this fills me with a feeling that I can only assume
normal people would describe as happiness
anyway
I absolutely could not be fkd cooking dinner tonight
so I decided to throw it together in the afternoon
so that when the evening rolls around
it might actually feel like somebody else cook for me
I'm trying out a new recipe
which I'm affectionately calling
“Chuck a whole lot of random shit in a pot
cook it on low and hope for the best”
we might need a workshop the name
but a slow cooked meal is ideal because it frees me up to do other things
like care for the children
and maybe even tackle some of my husband's jobs
and one thing I learnt through that experience
is it's not actually that hard
and dare I say it it's quite fun
made even more fun by the fact that children don't dare bother you
while you have loud machine in your hands
Which leads me to conclude that the menfolk
have been gatekeeping once again
by the time I finished the housework
the childcare and the yard work
the dinner had largely cooked itself
all I needed to do was pair a grain with it
bake some bread and throw together a salad
so really, not that much
and then everybody requested pudding
as they do almost every night
so I put my daughter to work
and together we whipped up a dark chocolate hazelnut
self saucing pudding from scratch
and it was absolutely fkn delicious if I'm honest
and the dopamine from the chocolate made
all of the day’s hard work
almost feel worth it